the US has been flying this spacecraft
since 2010 called the X-37B it was
recently loaded into a SpaceX Falcon
heavy rocket and then blasted into space
on a super secret mission right before
the new year with very few details
revealed about where it's going how long
it will be up there and what it'll be
doing and that happened just 2 weeks
after China launched its own mysterious
space plane the classified nature of
these missions has fueled all kinds of
speculation about where these ples might
be going and whether they could be used
as space weapons so I called a few
experts to learn more about what they
might actually be up to here's what we
know although the US's X-37B looks a lot
like NASA's former space shuttle it's
only about a quarter of the size it's
autonomous and it doesn't require a crew
of humans and then check this out when
its missions are complete the X-37B de
orbits and lands back on earth like an
airplane that's why the x37 is an
amazing kick building it's reusable it's
it's returnable it's refurbish but it
isn't an enormous vehicle that's limited
by having to have humans on board
because it's uncrewed the X-37B can stay
in space for years and Boeing the
company that makes it says that since
2010 it has completed 6 missions
traveled 1.3 billion miles and deployed
for more than 900 days straight so what
does the X-37B do when it's in Space the
official answer is lots and lots of
classified experiments take a look at
this animation you can see the X-37B
flying with its doors open which enables
it to expose materials in space and
carry out all kinds of different tests
we do have a little bit of insight into
some of the experiments it's done in the
past for example we know that the X-37B
has hosted a power beaming system
technology that could one day enable
satellites to send solar power down to
earth and we also know it carried an Air
Force Academy Satellite into space
before deploying it the experts I talked
to said it could also be used to test
materials for satellites or space
sensors in various parts of space this
is National Security related counter you
know the Russian Chinese capabilities
that are coming up there are you know
many many experiments and many things
you would want to do in space that
frankly we would not want peer
competitors to know about just as they
hide things from us so let's talk about
some of the speculation like that the
X-37B is some kind of space bomber or
that it could be used to test weapons
there isn't a lot of common sense behind
trying to do offensive weapons in space
they sound great in science fiction but
for many practical reasons they don't
make a lot of sense but no there's
there's absolutely no evidence that x37
has been doing anything offensive in
space this painting unveiled by the US
space Operations Command also helped
fuel speculation that the X-37B could be
used to intercept adversary satellites
that's because amateur space Watchers
said hey that futuristic space vehicle
they're depicting that looks a lot like
the X-37B it's plausible you can dig out
satellites you know by going close and
blinding it to the lasers or something
like that you know it's all sorts of
possibilities but interfering with the
satellite is a little different than
actually scooping one out of the sky so
it's it actually turns out to be really
difficult to do an intercept of an
object in space from space for the very
simple reason that when when you are in
orbit around the Earth you're traveling
at a very very high speed High Velocity
after launching on its seventh Mission
the X-37B could be heading deeper into
space than ever before and that's why
this recent launch is getting a lot of
buzs not only did it Blast Off on a
falcon heavy which SpaceX says is
capable of going as far as Mars but the
space force dropped a few hints in press
releases saying that the vehicle will be
operating in new orbital regimes
experimenting with space domain
awareness Technologies and investigating
radiation effects to NASA materials that
means the spacecraft is probably going
Beyond low earth orbit where it has
operated before and it could potentially
even travel 22,000 mil out to
geosynchronous orbit there are a lot of
really interesting orbits that give you
new capabilities that cover different
parts of the planet as an example the
Russians have for many many years uh
used a type of orbit called a Mia orbit
which is a very high inclination orbit
so it takes them up to very high
altitude and then drops down to low
altitude and they can use those orbits
to get more time over a certain part of
the earth it gives you other advantages
that the Russians have utilized the
radiation clue in space Force's press
release could also suggest that the
X-37B will be spending time exposing
materials in the van Allen radiation
belts which have been deemed deadly to
some types of materials you have to take
that into account if you're going to
establish a satellite constellation
higher up but of course these professors
say these are just educated guesses
since no one really knows where the x37
B is heading against the backdrop of all
of this is an intensifying space race
between super powers and that includes
growing competition to develop and build
more space planes the NASA contracted
Sierra space Dreamchaser could
potentially fly this year and while
Russia hasn't made much progress on its
space planes in recent decades China has
we know that China has been eagerly
pursuing space planes for quite some
time the US says Beijing has been
developing two space planes though
details have been kept very secret and
they've been years behind the US in
flying them after one of them launched
in December General Saltzman the chief
of space operations for the US space
force said that that plane and the X-37B
are some of the most watched objects in
orbit right now and he said it is no
coincidence that China is trying to
match the US's timing and
[Music]
capabilities